special counsel Robert molars
investigation of Russian election
meddling is going into a new phase
reports say a grand jury has issued
subpoenas in connection with Donald
Trump juniors campaign meeting with a
Russian lawyer the special counsel is
using the grand jury to determine if
there was collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russian operatives during
the election the president denounced the
investigation again during a speech last
night the Russia story is a total
fabrication it's just an excuse for the
greatest loss in the history of American
politics that's our little Jeff Pigasus
in Washington Jeff good morning good
morning this grand jury signals that the
investigation has accelerated into
another gear now a year into the
investigation the FBI has been following
the money and sources tell us that that
is a big part of this probe just this
week we learned that the Special Counsel
is brought on an expert in foreign
bribery adding to the team of at least
14 veteran prosecutors digging into
these allegations of collusion and
possible financial wrongdoing the
president is already warned Special
Counsel Muller that delving into the
Trump family's personal finances would
be crossing a red line but firing Muller
would represent a red line on Capitol
Hill as well
just yesterday two bipartisan bills
introduced in Congress would essentially
prevent the president from firing the
Special Counsel and the White House had
a measured response to the grand jury's
special counsel to the president
Ty Cobb said quote the White House is
committed to fully cooperating with mr.
Muller Jeff Jeff Pegues thank you very
much